our faith
must propel us
based on what the word of god is saying
to us
it must move us to a place of where we
are to a place to where we need to go
[Music]
i'm still here that's right my name is
pastor corey brooks and i'm still here
in this tip for 100 days bring attention
and awareness to the violence in chicago
and also across america
i am here tonight with a friend all the
way from brooklyn who is staying on the
rooftop with me tonight as we talk about
these various issues so i want to say
welcome to our rooftop revelations i
want to jump right in and just
dig on a topic that has uh been on my
mind and having uh pastor gilmoros here
tonight from brooklyn is going to help
me with this topic
pastor one of the things i realize when
we talk about violence
and the work that we do
our work is very similar
and i realize
in this work that
politicians
uh try to policy their way through the
problems
but for us
it's more than policy it's about
using faith right to tackle these
problems
the question i want to ask you is
how do you believe that faith
fills the gap
uh when it comes to working in these
areas of violence right so so thank you
for that pastor brooks um i think that
politicians are called
to make policies
and passes a call
to people
and because we're called to people we
are definitely concerned about the
policies that politicians make
and therefore because of our faith
we must be engaged and involved in
policy because policy
again affects our people so when you
look in a policy
you have to look at it from a standpoint
from a humanistic standpoint
how would this affect the person that i
want it to help
and so you can't do policy on money you
can't do it on favoritism
it must be about people
you know jesus said something that um i
think that we should all remember and he
talked about the fact that
he said that the poor you'll always have
a month
and so his work and his daily life was
around the paul he was around people
who they considered to him a white
babbler they considered him that he was
a friend of the sinners because he was
around the people who
if you have the right policy they'll be
pulled out of poverty
and so i think that again politicians
need to make the right decision when
they're making policy to really help the
people
and
as we talk about
faith we live in this secular society
and
how do you think it is that faith
um
responds as we move into these
environments
i know for me uh faith is so important
because
with without
that god presence without that
godly
work
um
it's empty
and so my faith
is what
pushes me into action it's what causes
me to love people that's what causes me
to have uh love for my neighbors right
and and it's that faith is do you think
it's that faith that we need if we're
gonna change this issue that we're faced
with especially with uh the violence
yeah um i think for us too as well
is that we must have faith that that
moves god right i mean you have to have
faith to be in this cold for sure
but that faith that we're talking about
uh must propel us to action you can't
have faith without movement there is no
time in the bible
um where you have seen
that there were individuals who had
faith and will stand still
in in the sense of not moving forward
right so our faith
must propel us
based on what the word of god is saying
to us
it must move us to a place of where we
are to a place to where we need to go
and so i think that that is one thing
that is really powerful about faith it
drives you it pushes you it moves you in
the direction of god
well listen
it's all about having that good faith
that eli steele writes about and talks
about
shelby still
writes and talks about that good faith
and that's what we're trying to practice
so until then
until tomorrow
i'm gonna still be on this roof
please keep praying
please keep supporting
thank you to my fox family for giving us
this platform for rooftop revelations
until the next time
as i always say
peace
you